.
>> GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO TUCK TUCK TONIGHT.
I'M TULSI GABBARD STANDING IN
FOR TUCKER.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, IT LOOKS
LIKE REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND DEMOCRATS
WILL HOLD ON TO THE SENATE.
NOW, WE'VE SPENT ALL WEEK
HEARING NOTHING BUT PUNDITS
PONTIFICATING WHAT HAPPENED IN
THIS ELECTION.
IF YOU'RE LIKE ME, YOU HAD
ENOUGH OF THAT.
IT'S TIME TO TALK ACT WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT.
IT'S TIME FOR THOSE THAT
ACTUALLY GOT ELECTED TO PROVE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE
NOT JUST POLITICIANS, THAT THEY
ARE THERE IN WASHINGTON TO TAKE
ACTION TO PROTECT THE INTERESTS
AND FREEDOM OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHILE IN BALI
INSTEAD OF DELIVERING A
NECESSARY MESSAGE OF UNITY TO
ALL AMERICANS, PRESIDENT BIDEN
CHOSE TO ATTACK HALF THE COUNTRY
IMPLYING THE ONLY ACCEPTABLE
DEMOCRATIC OUTCOME IS A WIN FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> LET ME IS THAT RIGHT WITH A
FEW WORDS ABOUT THE RECENT
ELECTIONS HELD IN THE UNITED
STATES WHAT WE SAW IS THE
STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY AND SAW IT IN
ACTION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE PROVE AGAIN
THAT DEMOCRACY IS WHO WE ARE.
THERE'S A STRONG REJECTION OF
ELECTION DENIERS AT EVERY LEVEL,
THOSE SEEKING TO LEAD OUR STATES
AND THOSE IN CONGRESS AND THOSE
SEEKING TO OVERSEE THE
ELECTIONS.
THERE'S A STRONG REJECTION OF
VOTER INTIMIDATION.
>> THERE WERE NO CANDIDATES THAT
WERE IN FAVOR OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE OR DESTROYING
DEMOCRACY.
JOE BIDEN'S MESSAGE IS THE WRONG
APPROACH.
HERE'S THE TRUTH.
AS LONG AS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THE PERMANENT WASHINGTON
ELITE ARE WORKING HAPPENED AND
HAND WITH FOOL AND FACEBOOK AND
AS LONG AS GOOGLE CAN USE ITS
MONOPOLY POWER TO SKEW PUBLIC
OPINION, LITERALLY MANIPULATING
THE INFORMATION THAT WE AS
VOTERS ARE ALLOWED TO SEE, THEN
THERE'S NO DEMOCRACY.
A RECENT STUDY BY RESEARCHERS AT
NORTH CAROLINA STATE UNIVERSITY
FOUND THAT GOOGLE'S E-MAIL
SERVICE, G-MAIL RETAINED THE
MAJORITY OF LEFT WING CANDIDATE
E-MAILS AND SENDING THE MAJORITY
OF RIGHT WING CANDIDATE E-MAILS
TO THE SPAM FOLDER.
GOOGLE HAS LIMITED VARIOUS
CONSERVATIVE WEBSITES.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THESE KINDS OF
CHANGES CAN HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT
ON VOTING.
A PEER REVIEWED 2015 STUDY
PUBLISHED IN THE PROCEEDINGS OF
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCE,
SEARCH ENGINES LIKE GOOGLE CAN
SWAY VOTERS 20% OR MORE.
WE'VE HEARD POLITICIANS SAYING
THEY ARE COMMITTED TO DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED RIGHT NOW.
LEADERS THAT ARE SERIOUS ANT
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND FINDING COMMON SENSE
SOLUTIONS TO THE MANY CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE.
THE REALITY IS THE MARGINS OF
THIS ELECTION ACROSS THE BOARD
ARE RAZOR THIN.
NO MATTER HOW THINGS SHAKE OUT
WITH THESE RESULTS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN ANNOUNCED, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE TO FIND A
WAY TO WORK TOGETHER IF THERE'S
ANY HOPE OF GETTING ANYTHING
DONE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING IS BOTH SIDES HARDENING
THEIR POSITION.
NOW, WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CANNOT AFFORD FOR CONGRESS TO BE
PARALYZED BIPARTISAN GRIDLOCK
THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
THERE'S TOO MUCH TO BE DONE.
EVERY PERSON IN CONGRESS SHOULD
SEE THEMSELVES AS AN INDEPENDENT
WHO IS NOT BEHOLDEN TO ANY
POLITICAL PARTY BUT ONLY TO
THEIR CONSTITUENTS, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
READY AND WILLING TO WORK WITH
THEIR COLLEAGUES.
IT WON'T BE EASY.
I KNOW.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
LEADERSHIP, COURAGE, RESPECT AND
HUMILITY.
WHEN I WAS A DEMOCRAT IN
CONGRESS AND I INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION, I ALWAYS SOUGHT OUT
AND FOUND REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS THAT WERE WILLING TO
WORK TOGETHER ON ACTUALLY
SOLVING PROBLEMS.
IT'S HARD.
BUT IT CAN BE DONE.
IT MUST BE DONE.
I'M NOT ADVOCATING
BIPARTISANSHIP JUST FOR THE SAKE
OF BIPARTISANSHIP.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT COMING
TOGETHER AS AMERICANS TO WORK
FOR THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY SERVE.
US.
THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
THERE'S MANY CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING.
HERE ARE A FEW WAYS WHERE
CONGRESS SHOULD MAKE A START.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE MUST
SECURE OUR BORDERS.
WE HAVE TO USE THE POWER OF THE
PURSE TO CLOSE THE BORDER AND
MAKE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT IF
YOU'VE COME IN THROUGH BIDEN'S
OPEN DOOR, YOU HAVE TO GO BACK
TO WHEREVER YOU CAME FROM.
IF YOU WANT TO COME BACK IN, YOU
HAVE TO FOLLOW OUR LAWS.
A FEW WEEKS AGO, I WAS IN
McALLEN, TEXAS, THE BUSIEST SPOT
OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER FOR
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS WHERE
CONGRESSMAN MYRA FLORES AND HER
HUSBAND, A CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL AGENT, THEY SHOWED ME
WHERE THERE'S A HUGE GAP IN THE
BORDER WELL.
AS WE DROVE OUT, WE SAW PILES
AND PILES OF BUILDING MATERIALS
THAT WERE PURCHASED FOR THE WALL
STACKED ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD
UNUSED.
THINGS THAT WE ALREADY PAID FOR.
SO I ASKED WHY AREN'T THEY BEING
USED?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WON'T
ALLOW CONTINUED CONSTRUCTION OF
THE WALL.
THEY ALSO WON'T ALLOW THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS TO USE THE
MATERIALS THAT WE ALREADY BOUGHT
TO SECURE THEIR OWN BORDER.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN McALLEN IS OCCURRING ALL
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
BILL MELUGIN REPORTED THIS
WEEKEND IN EEKLE PASS.
>> IN NORMANDY TEXAS, EARLY
WEDNESDAY MORNING, A MASSIVE
GROUP OF MIGRANTS CROSSES
ILLEGALLY TO THIS TINY TOWN.
HUNDREDS OF THESE I'M SUPREME
COURTED BY THE TEXAS NATIONAL
GUARD AND BORDER PATROL IN A
SINGLE FILE LINE STRETCHING
ALMOST AS FAR AS THE EYE CAN
SEE.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> THE MIGRANTS ARE
PREDOMINANTLY COUNTRIES THAT
TITLE 42, APOLICY THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO BE EXPELLED, IS RARELY
USED.
AT THE SAME TIME, ANOTHER GROUP
OF 400 CROSSED INTO EAGLE PASS.
MOST OF THEM SINGLE ADULT MEN.
>> OVER THE WEEKEND, THE WHITE
HOUSE FORCED THE RESIGNATION OF
THE COMMISSIONER OF THE BORDER
PROTECTION.
CHRIS MAGMUS.
IT WAS AN EFFORT TO SHIFT BLAME.
THE PRESIDENT, THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND SECRETARY
MAYORKAS.
WE CAN'T LET THEM GET AWAY WITH
THIS.
SO THE QUESTION IS, IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REALLY GOING TO
ACTUALLY CHANGE ITS POLICY AND
MAKE IT CLEAR TO PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD THAT ANYONE THAT COMES
IN TO THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
WILL BE SEND BACK TO WHERE THEY
CAME FROM.
HONESTLY, I DON'T HAVE MUCH
FAITH THIS WILL HAPPEN.
IF IT WERE, THEY WOULD HAVE
ALREADY DONE IT.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
IN THIS COUNTRY THAN PROTECTING
OUR GOD-GIVEN RIGHTS ENSHRINED
IN THE CONSTITUTION.
THESE VERY FREEDOMS AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES ARE UNDER ATTACK.
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
THIS NEW CONGRESS COMING IN MUST
TAKE THIS PROMISE THAT THEY MAKE
WHEN THEY TAKE THEIR OATH OF
OFFICE SERIOUSLY TO SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND WORK TO
PROTECT OUR CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
END THE GROSS OVERREACH OF
GOVERNMENT.
GET RID OF PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW
FOR SECRET FISA COURTS AND
WIRETAPPING OF AMERICANS AND A
NO FLY LIST THAT HAS NO DUE PRO
SOS.
THE USE OF ESPIONAGE AFTER TO GO
AFTER POLITICAL DISSIDENTS AND
MORE.
THEY NEED TO EXERCISE THEIROVER
SIGHT AUTHORITY TO STOP THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
UNDERMINE OUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH
AND SILENCING POLITICAL
OPPONENTS BY POLITICIZING
AGENCIES LIKE THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO GO
AFTER THEM AND BY GETTING BIG
TECH AND SOCIAL MEDIA TO SENOR
VOICES THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
HEAR.
TWITTER SCHEDULE ADD MEETING TO
DEBRIEF TOP WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS ON VACCINE
MISINFORMATION.
TWITTER SEN SENSED THAT "MISS
INFORMATION" SOME OF WHICH LATER
TURNED OUT TO BE TRUE.
IN A PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS
CASE, OFFICIALS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND PFIZER URGED TWITTER
TO BAN JOURNALISTS THAT REPORTED
THAT VACCINES DON'T STOP THE
VIRUS.
THERE WERE INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS AT TWITTER IN AN
APRIL 2021 MEETING.
ONE TWITTER EMPLOYEE WRITING
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE WANTED TO
KNOW ABOUT ALEX BANRENSON.
IT WAS SHOWED THAT HE WAS THE
CENTER OF INFORMATION.
WITHIN THE MONTH, TWITTER BANNED
BARONSON.
MEANWHILE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITIES DOMESTIC
TERROR USE ANY ARE BANNING
PARENTS.
THEY DRAGGED NONVIOLENT PRO LIFE
ACTIVISTS IN FRONT OF THEIR
KIDS.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHY YOU'RE
BANGING ON MY DOOR WITH A GUN.
>> YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TELL ME
ANYTHING?
CAN I HAVE YOUR NAME?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE ME YOUR
NAME OR ANY INFORMATION?
>> WHEN MY KIDS GO OUT TO THE
CAR TO GO TO SCHOOL AND THE FBI
PULLS UP ARMED, RUNNING TO THE
DOOR AND ONE OF THEM GOES TO THE
KIDS AND HOLDS THE KID WITH A
LONG GUN, THE SIDE OF MY
DRIVEWAY AND DOES NOT LET THEM
GO IN THE HOUSE, THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY AS ANY WIFE SAID
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> INSTEAD OF CURBING THESE
ABUSES OF POWER, CONGRESS HAS
ENABLED THEM.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT FURTHER
ABUSE OF POWER, CONGRESS NEEDS
TO USE THE POWER OF THE PURSE
AND IMMEDIATELY HAD THE IRS
FUNDING OF 87,000 NEW IRS AGENTS
THAT WILL BE HARASSING EVERYDAY
AMERICANS.
THE IRS HAS A TROUBLING HISTORY
OF TARGETING GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS BASED ON THEIR
POLITICS.
YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER LOIS
LEARNER TARGETED CONSERVATIVES.
CONGRESS DID NOTHING TO HOLD HER
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY MUST TAKE ACTION NOW BEFORE
IT'S TOO LATE.
BECAUSE THE IRV IS NOW ALREADY
ONE OF THE MOST HEAVILY ARMED
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> IT'S VERY INTERESTING, A LOT
OF THE SPECIAL AGENTS THAT WORK
FOR THE IRS, THEY DON'T COME
FROM A LAW ENFORCEMENT
BACKGROUND.
WE GET TO DO THE SAME THINGS
LIKE THE OTHER OFFICERS DO.
THINGS HAPPEN, WE HAVE TO
RESPOND.
>> SO WE TEACH OUR AGENTS TO
FIRE A FIREARM, TO BE ABLE TO
SHOOT.
WE TEACH THEM DEFENSIVE TACTICS
AND METHODS OF DEFENDING
THEMSELVES.
SO THEY GO THROUGH THAT ENTIRE
PROCESS SO THAT NOT ONLY CAN
THEY ANALYZE RECORDS BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMPONENT.
>> WE DO CARRY WEAPONS.
WE CARRY HANDCUFFS.
>> WHY IN THE WORLD DO IRS
AGENTS NEED TO CARRY WEAPONS AND
HANDCUFFS?
MOST OF THEIR WORK CONCERNS
CIVIL MATTERS NOT APPREHENDING
VIOLENT CRIMINALS.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE REMEMBER THAT
FOREIGN POLICY IS DOMESTIC
POLICY.
WE HAVE POLITICIANS FROM BOTH
POLITICAL PARTIES THAT ARE THE
PERMANENT WASHINGTON ELITE AND
WHO MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT THEY'RE DOING WITH OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND HOW THEY'RE
UNDERMINING NATIONAL SECURITY AS
THEY PUSH US CLOSER AND CLOSER
TO THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR
CATASTROPHE.
THEY HAVE TO DEMAND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE TENS OF
BILLIONS THAT THEY SENT TO
UKRAINE SO FAR.
THE BLANK CHECK IS NOT JUST FOR
UKRAINE, IT'S FOR THE MILITARY
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX THAT HAS MADE
TRILLIONS OFF OF OUR WARS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND THE MIDDLE EAST.
NOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THEY WANT TO HIRE 87,000 NEW IRS
AGENTS TO GO OVER EVER RERECEIPT
AND EVERY DEDUCTIBLE OF AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS WITH A FINE TOOTH COMB
SQUEEZING EVERY PENNY THAT THEY
CAN PRESIDENT THE UKRAINE
GOVERNMENT AND CORRUPT
BUREAUCRATS AND OLIGARCHS, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION REQUIRES NO
RECEIPTS AT ALL.
WHY IS THIS?
IT'S BECAUSE THEY KNOW MOST OF
THIS MONEY IS GOING TO CORRUPT
BUREAUCRATS.
THEY KNOW THIS.
THEIR ACTION EXPOSE WHO THEY
ARE.
IT'S NOT US.
WHEEL THEY'RE SHAPING TAXPAYER
DOLLARS OVERSEAS, THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND CONGRESS IS
FAILING TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
SOLDIERS AND VETERANS.
THOSE THAT ARE NOT GETTING THE
CARE OF NEED FOR SERVICE
INJURIES AND DISEASES.
IF THE NEW CONGRESS TAKES ACTION
ON ALL OF THESE AREAS, IF THEY
SOLVE THE BORDER CRISIS, CURB
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ABUSE OF
POWER.
IF THEY PROTECT CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND THIS UNCONDITIONALLY ENDLESS
FUNDING OF THE WAR IN UKRAIN